quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar
como algo básico cómo caracterizaría hoy
el rol y la participación de las mujeres
en los sistemas económicos qué lugar
ocupan en la toma de decisiones
muchas gracias por la invitación para mí
es un gusto y un honor compartir con
todos ustedes desde el ecuador la mitad
del mundo cuando nosotros revisamos
datos de la política y las
organizaciones actualmente existen siete
puntos 7 billones de habitantes de 195
países donde el 21 por ciento
son mujeres
cuando hablamos a nivel ejecutivo sólo
el 8 por ciento están en alta dirección
cuando revisamos la publicación de de
rating de porte 1 500 sólo el 5 por
ciento son sí según mccain si también
nos menciona que a la medida que
avanzamos hacia la parte de liderazgos
si a la alta gerencia se va perdiendo se
va disolviendo a las mujeres en el
camino en esta carrera profesional
catalina la pandemia como ya se ha
informado ha hecho estragos en la
participación laboral de las mujeres y
lo volvió a alertar la alta comisionada
de la onu para los derechos humanos
michelle bachelet cómo contrarrestar
estos efectos
bueno si en realidad es lo que
corresponde américa latina hay un alto
porcentaje hay alrededor de 26 millones
de trabajos que que fueron prácticamente
abandonados por este tema de la pandemia
por este tema de la economía también y
donde fue afectado las mujeres es por
eso que a nivel regional se ha
incrementado el trabajo de la mujer
informal han crecido todo lo que son
emprendimientos por eso este tipo de
foros lo que hace es abrir todos estos
caminos de negocios innovación
emprendimiento social educación finanzas
tecnología que es súper importante tener
esas herramientas de esas competencias
para lograr salir adelante más en una
participación donde el ecuador ocupa el
primer lugar en emprendimientos luego
sigue colombia luego sigue chile luego
sigue brasil
caterina hay algo que usted acaba
precisamente de mencionar y que es clave
y que está muy vinculado a esto me
refiero al acceso a la educación hay
aquí una brecha muy significativa entre
hombres y mujeres también verdad
y cuando nosotros hablamos de igualdad y
cuando nosotros hablamos de
empoderamiento y hay espacios de
desigualdad es así por ejemplo en el
emprendimiento la educación y lo hemos
visto ya luego de una pandemia donde la
pandemia fue para todos pero la forma de
vivirlos no fue así de tal manera que
muchos se quedaron sin estudiar sin
acceso a la educación si hay algo que
nosotros como web podemos afirmar es que
el puente de llegada para cerrar una
brecha es la educación por eso nosotros
desde web ecuador también incluimos esas
alianzas de esas articulaciones al
tercero y cuarto nivel porque es
importante trabajar para todos aquellos
que vienen detrás de nosotros por eso
para nosotros es importante abrir todos
estos caminos estas reflexiones mejores
prácticas que traen estos 119 los
mejores expliquen
de más de 19 países